Today, we're going to be speaking to William
Irvine, who's a professor of philosophy at
Wright State University and author of many
books, including the one I most recently read,
A Guide to the Good Life, The Ancient Art
of Stoic Joy.
So great to have you on.
I really appreciate your time.
Oh, my pleasure to be here.
So I think I think that this stoicism is a
particularly relevant topic right now for
all those following American politics and
thinking about the next few weeks.
But before we we so obviously link these ideas
to what's going on.
Maybe we can speak a little generally about
the ideas of stoicism and some of the most
notable purveyors of these ideas that you
write about, including Seneca and Marcus Aurelius
and and others.
Maybe first you can disabuse some of our audience
about what Stoicism is not, which is maybe
an indifference to what is going on in the
world, an indifference to tragedy and indifference
to the struggles of life.
That's not what it is.
As you write about in the book.
What's the right thought process for thinking
about stoicism?
Yeah, the strange thing is the Stoics turn
out to have been cheerful individuals and
you wouldn't think that.
So I like to distinguish between lower case
as Stoics and these are people who are simply
gloomy and glum.
And they just their idea of what you do in
life is you just stand there and withstand
whatever life throws at you.
And that's not the Stoics uppercase as Stoics
at all.
And these were individuals.
You mentioned some of the names, people like
Seneca, people like like Epictetus, people
like Marcus Aurelius, who on realized life
is tough.
And so you have to have a strategy for dealing
with a life that, you know is going to be
tough in there.
They were not anti emotion.
They were anti negative emotions.
And they thought quite sensibly that what
you should do in your life is you should try
to minimize the number of negative emotions
you experience.
And these are emotions like anger, anxiety,
envy and grief.
But they had absolutely nothing against positive
emotions.
And in fact, they thought we should be embracing
positive emotions.
Positive emotions are different than pleasures.
Okay.
So it's a important distinction, but positive
emotions like feelings of delight and even
feelings of joy.
That's what we should be in pursuit of.
And these guys were the preeminent psychologists
of their time, and they hit upon some psychological
strategies that work wonderfully well.
And so what I've done in my books is I've
tried to share those strategies with a broader
public.
So I think that this will help.
A lot of this is just the timing of this conversation.
It is beautifully timed because I think many
of the things you talk about in the book,
including negative visualization and understanding
the dichotomy, are really the tri Kotomi of
control.
These things are so relevant for anybody who
is worried about the election results that
we are waiting for.
Can you talk a little bit about maybe to start
with the idea of negative visualization and
its sort of relevance to day to day life?
Yeah.
Negative visualizations as simple technique.
And what you do is you pause in your daily
business.
It only takes a few seconds to do.
And you think about something that's important
to you, something that plays a very significant
role in your life.
And it could be your job.
It could be your spouse or your significant
other.
It could be your children.
And now take a moment to imagine that that
thing disappeared from your life.
And there are lots of ways that can harm,
you know, people.
Many people have recently lost a job or split
up with their significant others.
Imagine that happening.
And now the point is you don't dwell on that
because that would be a recipe for a miserable
existence.
What you do instead is you allow yourself
to have a few seconds in which you really
think about that, then go on with your daily
business.
And it's almost a magical effect, because
next time you encounter the person that you
imagined losing or you imagine being separated
from, it'll be a different experience because
you will no longer be taking that person for
granted.
And that's the problem with human existence.
You know, whatever we're whatever we we have
and worked so hard to get, once we've got
it, we take it for granted.
And we think, oh, well, this is fine.
But, you know, if only I had some more, you
know, a different, significant other a different
job, I would finally be happy.
So we put ourselves on this treadmill.
And what a sad way to spend the one life that
you have to live.
Yes.
Sometimes the concept of He Doneck adaptation
is used for this sort of way in which we as
humans very quickly establish the status quo
as a new baseline, even if it's better, for
example, or it could be worse.
But even if it's better than 99 percent of
our prior existence on the planet, it very
quickly becomes the new baseline from which
our existence is sort of judged.
Am I wrong to think that the idea of negative
visualization may be a sort of antidote to
that adaptation that takes place?
Yeah, it's it's like it's like an ointment.
You know, when you start taking your life
for for granted, it's anointment that you
can apply as needed.
And and it is interesting, you know, Stoics
and they aren't alone in doing this, but a
lot of the philosophies of the ancient world
advised you to not only be a spectator of
the lives of other people, which is what we
kind of instinctively do.
But be a spectator of your own life.
Watch yourself.
Watch what motivates you.
Watch the way you react to the events of the
day.
And then really think about what you're doing,
because, you know, you can look around you
and you can see people who work so hard to
get something and they finally get it.
And they're really, really happy for an hour,
a day or maybe a week.
And then the new wears off and they're right
back where they were before.
You know, it's it's like a poor a poor, poor
guy chasing mirages across the desert.
You know, off there in the distance there's
water.
And if only I can crawl to it, I will at last
have water to drink.
Gets there and it it evaporates.
It's gone.
Right.
And then just has to do that again.
You've got, like I say, well, life to live.
And, you know, what we do is we look around,
we see how other people are living their lives
and we assume somebody has done their homework.
Somebody somewhere has figured this out.
So I'll just copy them.
But throughout the millennia, there have been
people who have stood back and looked at this
and said, you know, nobody's done their homework.
And by by doing what?
But other people are doing in this case, you're
only going to get yourself in trouble at some
kind of superficial level that this might
sound very anti sort of consumerist.
The idea that there's no product one can buy
that is going to sort of give them whatever
degree of happiness they might imagine they
would achieve by by buying a certain product.
But when I read the book, I got more the impression
that it's not necessarily that, but it's more
about making decisions consciously and thoughtfully
and and not just writing off where we get
and maintaining that appreciation.
Can you comment about that a little bit?
I mean, this is it doesn't sound necessarily
like an anticapitalist or anti consumer culture
ideology, but it's more about recognizing
and understanding how we are sort of wired,
in a sense, to very quickly adjust to whatever
it is that we have.
Yeah.
You know, if you if you believe in evolution,
I and I do.
Our ancestors back in Africa who were perfectly
happy with what they had.
They didn't survive.
They didn't spread their their genes.
The ones that survived were the ones that
were constantly thinking about things that
had happened, trying to learn from them.
So they didn't make the mistakes over.
Kind to think about what was going to happen.
You know, this idea, this this dream of living
in the present moment, our ancestors on the
savannas of Africa who did that got eaten
by a lion, you know, and that was that was
the end of of their story.
So there is this thing that I refer to as
the Gap Theory of happiness, and that is that
there is a gap between what you have and what
you want.
And then.
So one way to close that gap and gain happiness
is by working hard to get the thing that you
want.
But there's another way, and that is reverse
the gap the other way.
You learn to want the things you already have
because and there there will be a lot of people
who who reject this claim on the face of it.
You have so much in your life and whatever
it is you think you absolutely need to have,
look at your life and look at how your ancestors
would have looked at your life.
They would have regarded you as dreaming,
as living in a dream world.
You have all of this stuff.
What?
You have a device in your pocket that cannot
only talk to somebody in China, but you can
see them talking while you do it.
That's just crazy.
And yet here, people.
And people now, you know, when they don't
have the latest model cell phone, they feel,
well, you know, my life is ruined.
So take what you already have.
Learn to appreciate it.
Learn to be thankful for the existence you
find yourself living.
Learn to embrace your life.
And now if you look back at the at the Stoics.
They didn't simply go into dormant mode where
they said, OK, I'm fine with that.
They they turned out to be some very productive
and ambitious people.
Seneca, for instance, besides being a philosopher,
was an adviser to an emperor, was the first
century A.D. equivalent of a billionaire and
was one of the greatest playwrights of his
time.
So he was no slouch.
But, you know, the idea of waking up in the
morning and just feeling wonderful that you
get to be having the life that you're having.
And a large part of that is your own attitude
and your own attitude can be is very much
in your control.
So let's that's a perfect Segway.
So the one of the things that I see with my
audience that is causing significant anxiety
as we get closer to this election.
And my audience, being a left leaning audience,
is overwhelmingly folks who want to see Donald
Trump go is what have I done enough?
I have anxiety about the results.
And if we introduce the idea of a dichotomy
of control where we would separate things
into that which we can control than that which
we cannot control, it sort of falls short
when it comes to something like an election,
which is where the idea of the Tricon Ayumi
of control is is so useful, those things over
which we have some control.
And I think in the book you talk about a tennis
match where ultimately you don't really have
unilateral control of the results.
But certainly you can have control over your
practice plan.
You can have control over your attitude and
expectations going into the match, et cetera.
And for me, that's been a perfect analogy
to the election where, well, we're all voters.
And as voters, we do have some control and
we control our one vote.
We also can decide whether to phone bank or
not and if so, in which states.
But ultimately with one hundred and thirty
or one hundred and thirty five million expected
votes, no one of us can control the results.
So can you.
Can you give us a sense of a healthy way to
sort of apply this to something like a national
election with a not infinite but very large
number of moving parts, many of which over
we don't have control?
Yeah, this is the most complicated election
of my lifetime.
So much going on, so much unpredictability.
And I'm ready to be surprised.
That's my plan going into it.
And, you know, the last election in 2016,
I'm an extreme early riser.
And I was up at about 2:00 in the morning
and I turned on the TV expecting to see Hillary's
face there beaming.
And it was Donald Trump instead.
And I thought, wow.
So I'm ready for for absolutely anything.
The dichotomy of control.
There are things you can control and things
you can't.
And if you spend your time worrying about
things you can't control, you're going to
be a very anxious and unhappy individual.
So think about things you can control and
do those to the best of your ability.
So in the case of a tennis match, you can
control how hard you train.
You can control whether you party the night
before her, whether you tried to get a good
night's sleep.
You can control your strategy.
Can you control how hard the other person
practices?
No, you can't.
So that does that isn't even part of your
equation in.
By the way, we come into the notion here of
success and failure.
So for a stoic what counts as success?
Success is to put it into a motto.
Success is doing what you could with what
you had, where you were.
If you did those things, you have succeeded
because what else could you do?
Right.
You did what you could with the election.
Stoics would have a two stage plan.
Number one is don't worry about things you
have no control over.
And number two is be emotionally prepared
for surprises.
So the Stoics were were big on what I call
stoic training, where you go out of your way
to do things that are difficult just because
they're hard to do, do things where there's
a significant chance of failure, not catastrophic
failure, but failure in some sense of the
word.
How come?
Just so you can get used to failing.
You know, successful people are typically
people who have experienced a lot of failure.
What makes them special is when they failed.
They didn't break.
They bounced.
They took the failure.
They learned from the failure.
They went on to do new, better failures than
they had before.
And finally popped out at the end of the tunnel.
What's conventionally called a successful
person.
So with this.
Prepare yourself for just about anything emotionally
and just say don't know where it's going.
But wherever it it goes, what I will do is
I will do what I can with what I've got, where
I am.
We will pause our conversation
with Professor of Philosophy William Irvine
there.
The full conversation will be available on
our YouTube channel, YouTube dot com, slash
the David Pakman show very soon.
We will go to
a quick break on
the podcast radio PROTE program and TV show
and
be
very
back very, very soon.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.